Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa
Hommage au Bouddha, le béni, le saint, le parfaitement illuminé par lui-même.
Je voudrais vous parler des principes de base de la méditation.
et notamment des empêchements.
Et ensuite, ceux qui n'ont médité que depuis à peu près un an sont invités à venir en bas au réfectoire pour poser certaines questions.
Quel est le but de la méditation ?
Le Bouddha lui-même était très clair à ce sujet.
Il a dit, « Je n'enseigne que dukkha et la cessation du dukkha.
» Nous devons donc comprendre ce qu'il a dit par dukkha.
Nous devons donc comprendre ce qu'il voulait dire par dukkha.
Il y a trois sortes de dukkha.
Le premier, c'est dukkha-dukkha.
C'est la souffrance.
Une souffrance que personne ne peut nier.
C'est la souffrance due aux émotions, aux difficultés d'ordre physique.
Il y a ensuite un deuxième niveau de souffrance qui vient du fait que les choses sont transitoires.
On espère toujours que les choses vont durer.
Mais elles n'en finissent pas de disparaître.
Et tout ceci va provoquer l'apparition d'états d'esprit comme l'avidité, la nostalgie et la peur de perdre ce que l'on a acquis.
Et la troisième forme de souffrance est encore plus subtile, elle a à voir avec la façon dont nous expérimentons les choses et dont nous voyons la réalité.
Et l'objet le plus solide que nous expérimentons, c'est nous-mêmes.
Je pense que j'existe réellement.
C'est un très grand problème.
Donc, la méditation, c'est l'investigation de ces trois vues fausses.
peut-être pas des vues fausses, mais des interprétations incorrectes de Dukkha.
Comment allons-nous faire pour nous investiguer nous-mêmes ?
De façon objective et scientifique.
Parce que d'ordinaire nous nous contentons d'expérimenter les choses et de nous sentir exister.
Et donc la méditation va nous donner la possibilité de trouver à l'intérieur de nous un endroit à partir duquel nous allons pouvoir nous observer nous-mêmes.
J'ai l'image d'un cône.
À la base du cône, il y a un cercle.
Et c'est là où les gens et nous
et c'est là que nous d'ordinaire nous vivons donc les choses se produisent et nous les recherchons ou au contraire nous essayons de les éviter donc la vie peut être expérimentée comme un cercle vicieux
Lorsque quelque chose d'agréable se présente, on le recherche.
Nous avons la langue qui porte de désirs, la soif, l'avidité, la possession.
Et lorsque c'est quelque chose de désagréable qui fait mal,
Nous en voyons, nous mordons, nous luttons contre.
Ou si c'est trop énorme, on s'enfuit.
La queue entre les jambes.
En d'autres mots, notre vie est conduite par...
donc la vie se passe à essayer de s'agripper à ce que l'on aime ou à éviter de s'enfuir lorsque c'est désagréable
Et cette espèce d'aller-retour constant entre ce que l'on aime, entre aimer et ne pas aimer, s'enracine dans une interprétation incorrecte de ce que nous sommes.
Maintenant c'est assez compréhensible, nous pouvons comprendre pourquoi nous avons fait cette erreur quand nous sommes arrivés à réaliser que nous pensons que nous sommes des êtres humains réaliser que nous nous présumons être des êtres humains
Lorsque nous allons réaliser que nous faisons une erreur en pensant que nous existons réellement en tant qu'êtres humains Nous sommes concrétisés dans ce corps
Mais le corps ne peut pas procurer constamment du plaisir.
Donc nous serons toujours en conflit avec ce corps.
Nous serons déçus.
Nous en aurons assez.
Nous allons souhaiter pouvoir être bionique.
bionique notre vie émotionnelle est conditionnée par les expériences passées
Et lorsque nous commençons à méditer, nous allons très vite nous rendre compte que nous n'avons pas beaucoup de contrôle sur cette vie émotionnelle.
Lorsqu'on va se coucher le soir, on ne peut jamais se dire demain je vais me lever déprimé.
Mais c'est ce qui se passe pourtant.
On ne peut pas savoir quand on sera heureux.
C'est possible que cet après-midi je me sente heureux, mais il est également possible que je ne me sente pas heureux.
Il est possible que je sois anxieux, ou déprimé, ou que j'en ai assez.
Serait-il possible d'atteindre une vie émotionnelle qui serait stable ?
D'être en permanence dans le calme, le bonheur, la paix.
C'est donc cela le défi que le Bouddha nous propose de relever.
Il a annoncé qu'il existait bel et bien un endroit
Et à partir de cette base calme, les relations de l'amour, de la joie et de la compassion arrivent.
Puis il y a la pensée et la pensée continue dans la tête.
Il y a encore les pensées et cette habitude de constamment être perdu dans les pensées.
Nous devons comprendre ce qui conditionne ces pensées à apparaître, d'où viennent-elles.
Quel est le rapport entre notre vie émotionnelle et les pensées ?
Dans notre culture et tout particulièrement depuis Descartes, nous avons fait une séparation entre l'esprit et le cœur.
nous pensons que l'esprit se résume à penser et à imaginer et que le coeur c'est essentiellement pour les émotions dans les cultures occidentales le mot qu'ils utilisent pour l'esprit c'est le même que pour les anciens grecs, Psyche, ça signifie les deux
Mais dans les philosophies asiatiques, le mot qui est utilisé pour l'esprit, c'est la psyché.
Nous devons donc essayer de voir le lien entre ce que l'esprit pense et ce que le cœur ressent.
Dans ce complexe psychophysique, il y a cette intelligence.
L'intelligence est normalement confusée par les émotions et les pensées.
L'intelligence est souvent perturbée par les pensées et les émotions.
L'intelligence pense que la pensée existe.
Dans notre méditation, nous faisons toutes ces différentes parties de notre
l'existence humaine, des objets à observer différentes parties de notre existence humaine le corps et ses sensations le cœur avec toutes ses émotions et ses moods
le cœur avec toutes ses émotions et ses humeurs et l'esprit avec ses imaginations et ses pensées.
Lorsqu'on commence à observer, à ressentir et à voir ces choses en tant qu'objectivement,
alors nous avons, comme si c'était le cas, désembêté nous-mêmes nous avons enlevé ce phénomène psychophysique Nous allons alors réussir à nous extraire de ce processus psychophysique Donc cette position de pouvoir observer nous-mêmes observer les sensations
l'endroit à partir duquel nous allons observer de façon détachée ces sensations, ces émotions, ces pensées c'est précisément le sommet du cône c'est la position de Vipassana
Et c'est là que se trouve vipassana, c'est la position du méditant vipassana.
Donc, très simplement, ce que nous essayons de faire, c'est d'observer ce qui se passe dans notre corps et dans notre esprit.
et si nous réussissons à observer objectivement ce corps, ce cœur et cet esprit ils ne feront plus partie de ce système psycho-physique et cela
C'est souvent expérimenté par le méditateur comme l'observateur ou l'expérimentateur ou le ressenteur quelque chose de séparé du corps, du cœur et de l'esprit Donc cette position, nous pouvons
nous pouvons développer ce statut volontairement.
Nous pouvons prendre l'habitude de retourner régulièrement à cet endroit pour pouvoir observer objectivement.
Mais ce n'est cependant pas encore le pur vipassana.
Parce qu'il y a encore toujours la sensation, l'impression qu'il y a quelqu'un qui observe, quelqu'un qui expérimente.
Qu'est-ce qui nous empêche de rester au sommet du cône ?
Comment est-ce que nous nous retrouvons dans le cercle en train de nous débattre ?
Ce sont ce que le Bouddha appelle les empêchements.
Mais ces choses ne sont que des empêchements que si nous nous sommes immergés dedans.
inévitablement, chaque fois que nous nous perdons, nous développons cette particularité.
Par exemple, si j'ai une inquiétude dans mon esprit, et que je me demande si j'ai laissé le gaz à l'eau ou pas, avant de venir à la rétrie,
Je me demande par exemple si je n'ai pas oublié le gaz avant de revenir à la retraite.
Cette idée commence à me gratter l'esprit.
L'anxiété monte, fuelled by the thought.
And before I know it, I'm in an anxious state, worrying what to do.
Et sans même m'en rendre compte, je me retrouve très vite dans un état d'anxiété, me demandant ce que je vais faire.
Alors, je me réveille de cet état et je prends conscience de la sensation d'anxiété.
Et avec ça, il y a eu l'anxiété.
Quand je suis tombé dans ce cercle, quand je suis tombé dans ce habit de craindre, j'ai renforcé ce habit.
Et donc au moment où la pensée est apparue dans mon esprit, aurais-je oublié le gaz, j'ai commencé à m'inquiéter, et le fait de tomber dans l'inquiétude va faire que cette tendance à être inquiet va se renforcer.
Donc vous voyez que le
Le processus de purification de l'esprit et du cœur est un processus très difficile parce que ces conditionnements sont très ancrés en nous.
Pour les débutants, par exemple, ceux qui débutent dans la méditation,
Il faut bien se rendre compte qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un succès qui sera rapidement obtenu.
Il faut penser en termes de 25 ans.
Alors, il est possible qu'on voit quelques petits changements.
Je ne veux pas vous dépresser.
Parce que, rappelez-vous que même si le progrès peut sembler lent, nos vies en fait deviennent beaucoup plus significatives.
Nous commençons à perdre ce sentiment de l'utilité de la vie.
nous commençons tout doucement à perdre cette impression que notre vie est inutile, qu'elle n'a pas de sens, que c'est une aliénation.
Et on ne se pose plus tellement la question de savoir pourquoi suis-je ici.
Donc, lorsque les empêchements vont se manifester, nous devons savoir quoi faire.
Et ceci, c'est directement en rapport avec l'habileté, l'art de méditer.
Donc dès qu'un désir se manifeste dans l'esprit, quel qu'il soit… Sexe, drugs and rock'n'roll !
Sexe, drugs et rock'n'roll !
Donc, dès qu'un désir se manifeste dans l'esprit, il faut être très rapide et le voir très vite.
S'il s'agit d'un désir sexuel, par exemple, il faut tout de suite le reconnaître comme tel et l'enregistrer comme tel.
puis l'on, comme ce soit, revient dans le corps et là vous ressentez l'excitation et vous attendez qu'elle passe et en restant là, l'on ressent le désir d'indulger ces pensées particulières
Et tout en faisant cela, la personne va ressentir le besoin, le désir de s'y complire.
Vous devez persévérer, continuer à observer et être intéressé par tout ce processus.
Vous devez bien observer de façon à voir en quoi consiste le désir et ce qu'il fait.
Voir la nature transitoire de ce processus.
Et voir que, parce que vous le regardez, vous le ressentez, vous l'expériencez, alors ça ne peut pas être vous.
et comprendre que, étant donné que vous êtes capable de le mettre à distance et de l'observer de façon objective, il est impossible que ce désir ce soit vous.
De temps à autre, vous pouvez vous répéter, « Non, non, non, ce n'est pas moi, ce n'est pas moi.
» Et donc, cette technique
Ce processus qui consiste à laisser venir le désir, l'observer objectivement et le voir passer, ce processus doit être appliqué à toutes les formes de désirs.
Et avec tout ce que nous n'aimons pas.
Par exemple, si vous avez une sensation d'irritation, d'énervement, vous devez la laisser pénétrer dans votre corps et l'observer.
Et n'oubliez pas qu'en réalité nous aimons être cruels, être fâchés.
Sans quoi nous ne le ferions pas.
Et donc, de cette façon, vous allez pouvoir attraper ce désir, le désir même d'être cette personne qui est fâchée.
Pauke him in the eye.
Donc maintenant vous voyez ce que les pensées passent dans le esprit d'un monstre.
Ensuite il y a ces émotions que nous n'aimons pas, qui sont douloureuses, comme la dépression, l'anxiété.
Alors, il y a également les émotions que nous n'aimons pas, comme la dépression, l'anxiété.
Ici, c'est notre refus, notre résistance que nous devons observer.
Nous devons laisser ces émotions s'exprimer librement.
de cette façon le cœur va se purifier voyez le cœur plutôt comme un système météo
donc il faut essayer de voir le cœur et l'esprit comme une station de météo parfois il y a de la pluie, des nuages, parfois il y a du soleil, ça change constamment il faut voir cela comme des énergies de turbulence
Il y a ensuite l'empêchement de la somnolence, de la torpeur, de la léthargie.
En fait, la somnolence, le sommeil, c'est un refuge.
Nous voyons le sommeil comme un refuge.
Lorsque nous sommes un peu déprimés ou un peu fatigués, nous nous mettrons sur la couche.
Quand la vie devient un peu trop difficile, il y a une pensée qui arrive dans la tête, dans les lumières néon.
Lorsque la vie devient trop difficile, il y a des lettres lumineuses qui apparaissent devant l'esprit.
Dans l'oubli, on ne souffre pas.
mais malheureusement, il faudra bien se réveiller.
Donc même dans le sommeil, il n'est pas possible de trouver un bonheur permanent.
Nibbana n'est en aucun cas un état d'oubli.
Nous utilisons notre sommeil
nous utilisons donc le sommeil pour échapper à ce que nous n'aimons pas mais nous utilisons également le sommeil tout simplement parce que nous l'aimons le dimanche matin on passe son temps au lit avec une tasse de thé et le journal ou du café
Et lorsqu'on est fatigué d'être dans une certaine position, on se retourne.
Il se rendort.
Et alors on se demande pourquoi on a l'impression d'être aussi fatigué.
Alors pourquoi s'étonner lorsqu'on s'assied pour méditer, pourquoi s'étonner de se sentir si fatigué ?
Et donc lorsque l'éthargie et la somnolence vont apparaître pendant la méditation, nous devons faire un réel effort pour rester éveillés.
Et nous devons prendre comme objet d'investigation cette sensation de torpeur, de lourdeur dans l'esprit comme si c'était du porridge.
Donc ce sont ces sensations de lourdeur dans l'esprit qui deviennent votre objet d'attention.
Et vous devez également observer votre désir de disparaître dans cette torpeur.
A l'opposé de la somnolence, il y a l'agitation.
Il y a l'agitation au niveau du corps, le besoin de toujours bouger, et l'agitation au niveau de l'esprit, toutes les pensées.
Donc, de la même manière, nous devons être très patient.
Lorsque l'esprit s'éloigne, vous le notez et vous revenez.
Et donc il faut être très prudent avec cela, dès que l'esprit se met à penser, il faut s'en rendre compte, en être conscient et ramener l'attention.
Si pendant toute l'heure vous passez votre temps à aller dépenser et ramener l'esprit, les penser, ramener l'esprit, c'est de la très bonne méditation.
C'est une très bonne méditation, c'est un effort très louable pour affaiblir, atténuer cette tendance à penser.
Et c'est la même chose avec le corps.
S'il y a de l'agitation dans le corps, il faut apprendre à se détendre et se relaxer autour de cette agitation.
Et attendre patiemment que ça passe.
Mais rappelez-vous que pendant tout cela, nous étudions les sensations.
Qu'est-ce que l'impatience ?
Et n'oubliez pas que, entre-temps, vous investiguez, vous cherchez à voir en quoi consiste réellement cette agitation.
Quelle est notre relation à cette agitation ?
La désire-t-on, ne la désire-t-on pas ?
La voulons, est-ce qu'on la veut, est-ce qu'on ne la veut pas ?
Et on attend jusqu'à ce que cela passe.
Et donc de cette façon nous allons commencer à comprendre la relation que nous avons avec ces différents états d'esprit et nous allons d'autre part laisser à ces états d'esprit la possibilité de disparaître.
Et la dernière hindrance est celle du doute.
Donc c'est le doute sur si vous pouvez faire la méditation ou si vous devriez la faire.
Donc quand le doute arrive dans la tête, sortez de la pensée dans le corps.
Donc lorsque le doute doit se manifester, laissez-le s'introduire dans le corps.
En quoi consiste le doute ?
Qu'est-ce que l'on ressent lorsque le doute est présent ?
Est-ce la peur de rater ?
Est-ce tout simplement de l'aversion, désir par le faire ?
Est-ce la peur de s'engager ?
Essayer de voir ce qui fait que l'esprit se met à douter.
et donc l'art de la méditation c'est la capacité à être conscient de notre relation avec tous ces états d'esprit de façon à pouvoir maintenir le plus longtemps possible l'état de témoin objectif au sommet du cône
Cette sensation dont je vous ai parlé précédemment d'être l'observateur, celui qui expérimente, celui qui ressent, je vous ai dit que ce n'était pas là le stade final de vipassana.
Et donc nous allons peut-être nous sentir être cette personne qui observe, qui ressent, qui expérimente.
Nous devons simplement prendre conscience de cet état d'esprit et revenir à l'observation pure de tout ce qui se passe en soi.
Et si nous procédons ainsi, nous allons, petit à petit, devenir de plus en plus concentrés sur l'instant présent, et nous allons devenir tellement intéressés et focalisés sur ce qui se passe
que cette sensation d'être quelqu'un qui observe va disparaître et bientôt il n'y aura plus que la pure observation, la pure expérimentation et ça c'est vipassana c'est voir les choses telles qu'elles sont réellement cela ne peut pas se faire par un acte de volonté
Cela ne peut pas se produire par la volonté.
Cela ne peut se produire que lorsque les conditions sont là pour que cela se produise.
Et ces conditions, c'est ce que le Bouddha a appelé les sept facteurs d'illumination.
Et nous allons faire un petit exercice et je vais les expliquer ce soir.
Mais je vous parlerai de cela ce soir car j'aimerais faire un peu d'exercice.
Mais ceci ne veut pas dire que vous ne pouvez pas pratiquer vipassana jusqu'à ce soir.